hello everyone and this episode of C++
tricks I'm redoing the first video I did
because I realized I did wrong after a
little bit of analysis and getting a
comment about it and yeah you're totally
right that is not the best way to get
the past and it's something I kind of
already knew but hadn't I guess
apparently decided to forget and go with
a weird other way so the way you should
be using if you want to path to your
assets or something for your project is
with file system while using the
underscore underscore path method does
work in a lot of situations it is
completely depends on your preprocessor
of your compiler so the results could
vary and that old way was it was
something like this it was just string a
path a equals file so that way we'll get
you the path to this C++ file but if
you're just I don't know packaging
everything up and shipping it out then
you're not necessarily gonna have the
source code with it and who knows what
this is going to be or if it will work
at all in a with a binary so that's kind
of an unreliable method might be okay
for testing and you know internal stuff
but yeah you don't want that in your
code in the long run C++ 17 implemented
a standard file system path and there's
a lot of examples of this online but
this came from the boost library and
originated back in like I think 2003 so
this has been around for a really long
time in the boost library and I've
actually used it before from booths
library and didn't even realize that it
got put in C plus seven C++ 17 so
yeah sorry about that but yeah this is
something that definitely developers
should be aware of so the better way to
do it would to give it a path from where
your binary builds or ships from so for
example if I look at my project here and
just go to I'm just using this as an
example your project could be different
but you could use this same code here
from this function and essentially do
the same thing so if I go to my project
here I'll just show you kind of what it
will do so this will give me the path
let's see when I build I'm going into
releases and then here it is so this is
my application and from here yeah i
would go back a directory and then into
assets so that's where this comes from
back a directory and into assets and
that way you can get the path and this
you know in a lot of ways can be this
path can be changed into a string if you
need to with just adding a dot string to
it so for example if i wanted to get the
length of this I could get the length of
the string by doing a dot string dot
size not necessarily something you need
to do but you should just know that yeah
turn it into a string is very easy and
if you want to get and you know all the
objects in the file all the all the
files in that folder and that path you
can basically do something like this you
take that you take that file name path
there it is I'm just doing it in a
function here and you can just loop
through it with standard file system
iterator on that path but with a
constand call entry whatever you want
and entry will be a path another path to
each file in that folder and so from
there you could check on them and do
what you want so for example you could
just see what they are with a simple see
out of entry
okay so yeah we have to do dot path on
the entry to go a little deeper then as
you'll see it does spit all those out
for everything it finds in that folder
okay so that's pretty much it hope you
guys enjoyed this first episode of C++
tricks let me know what other sort of
tricks do you think other people might
want to know for the next episode
otherwise I'll just come up with
something I think is useful and making
it the second episode hope you all have
a good day and I'll see you in the next
episode peace out